hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build I know it's been a
while and I apologize for that but I
thought it'd be fun to show you guys a
little bit of what went into making the
Christmas opening this year I've got a
little bit of footage from that of kind
of what went into making the puppet and
the sword and stuff like that so I
thought you guys would enjoy it take a
look
alright so Doug wanted to do this cool
intro for the Christmas holiday season
and stuff like that so we've been doing
these every year these sort of very
elaborate intros and this one's gonna be
kind of crazy and over the head top he
was describing it to me and as he was
describing it to me I was immediately
kind of getting ideas of kind of what I
thought he wanted or what I thought
would be cool and basically he seemed
very open or whatever but he was like
yeah we're gonna you know find outer
space into this other planet other
dimension or something and we're gonna
do battle with you know the great Earl
of the greatest lover of Christmas and
it's this crazy alien that looks like
the alien queen sort of the thing and we
battle it he's a guy I jump at it with a
giant sword and cut its belly open and
burst out and I'm hacking it up and all
this stuff and then we fly back in the
spaceship and we're all covered with
blood and muck and everything and so I
was like yeah okay and he's thinking
however you want to do that you know is
up to you so I might quickly sat down I
did a initial design of how I envisioned
the alien to be based on what he was
describing and he was like yeah sure
whatever that looks cool that's
basically it and I can kind of see it
does look have kind of an alien queen
sort of feel to it
so and then you know it's like well
you're gonna jump in with this giant
sword or whatever and stuff and I'm like
that has to look cool and stuff like
that so I came up with a design for you
know Christmas sword which he also was
like yeah sure that looks good so we're
just gonna jump right in I think I'm
gonna start working on the sword because
I feel like they'll be pretty easy I'm
just gonna grab some wood and we're
gonna plot out you know the design and
stuff like that and cut it and start
sanding it and assembling all the pieces
and stuff like that so that should be
pretty cool all right so I've got a nice
piece of poplar wood here a nice wood
plank it's five and a half inches by
three feet so I'm just gonna I'm gonna
plot out the design I'm gonna draw it on
there we'll cut it out I'll sand it down
and then I'm gonna make the kind of
Christmassy tree motif for the the hilt
and stuff like that
I keep using this just all-purpose
repair putty it dries pretty quick I've
never used this particular type before
so I'm going to test it out a little bit
it looks like it's pretty comparable to
the plastic well which I really used to
like that they don't make that product
anymore though unfortunately I have some
packs of sculpt but that takes a little
bit of time to cure and I want to just
kind of knock this out as quick as
possible so but we'll cut our handle and
stuff I've got a piece of oak here dowel
rod kind of measure out how long on with
the handle and stuff like that the
pummel at the end is gonna be s be round
whatever I wanted to look like a light
or like a nice big red shiny Christmas
ornament I'll see what I have that's I
wanted to have some weight to it or
whatever a little bit I don't want it to
break I want to I don't want to use
necessarily an actual ornament or even a
plastic one because it'll break too
easily
yeah we're gonna start to map out our
design onto the piece of wood and start
cutting
[Music]
my pattern all plotted out on here and I
take it over to the bandsaw there and
we're gonna cut it out as close to the
shape is I can there's some pieces
because it does extend out further than
the actual piece of wood I'm gonna have
to add some pieces and then all of this
is going to be sculpted using the the
epoxy whatever so yeah well cut it out
the basic shape and hopefully it doesn't
look like
[Music]
so I cut my handle I cut my groove and
attached I shot some screws through it
attached some nuts on the other end so
that's kind of good and secure and
fortunately I was sanding the blade I
dropped it and broke off some of the
pieces so I'm gonna attach those with
some wood glue and then once a putty
everything I should hold it all together
still so I still have to putty at all to
cover up the handle and stuff like that
and then we're gonna use the aluminum
tape to give the blade a nice kind of
finish
[Music]
as you see I'm starting to add some of
the putty that's gonna secure the handle
and they'll create I can start to sculpt
then my tree motif kind of on the hilt
also I added some screws to give myself
a little extra support because I'm gonna
extend these pieces out a little bit and
this piece broke off so it's actually
gonna help hold that piece together a
little bit and give this a little bit
more support so that when I start to
sculpt to that it has something to kind
of adhere to it's not just going to be a
lump of the epoxy and the tips there
[Music]
alright well this is what I got so far I
did add the bail at the end here some
red I have this tape but I don't know
this might be a little too thick I kind
of want it to be a little thinner lines
so I might just put white tape on it and
wrap it I've got some thin
color the Christmas tree sort of element
I wanted to have a metallic quality to
it but I also want it to be like a
really really dark green we probably
will shoot a green screen but it's
really really dark really really dark
forest green it may not it might be all
right
Becky okay and then I'm gonna lay the
metallic tape over the blade and then
we'll kind of tarnish it up a little bit
with the steel wool so that it doesn't
isn't too reflective and again it
doesn't catch a lot of that green on the
green screen which will be a problem
then for King and stuff like that
so you can see it's a pretty pretty
ridiculous
pretty epic looking Christmas sword I
think I will dub it the sword of eternal
Christmas
[Music]
lumen tape and gave it a nice kind of
brushing with the steel wool which kind
of dulls it a bit so it won't be as
reflective kind of makes a little bit
more looks a little more like steel and
then that way it won't reflect as much
we're in the green screen room so
ya see I added this little star here Rob
actually found a pair of glasses like
party glasses and he painted gold and
then I just took this little star kind
of gem in the center there and yeah he
just cut the lenses off the glasses or
whatever and painted them and glue them
on and then pummel here is kind of
putting it into place it's a little
crooked but gonna kind of get the job
done and then the candy cane tape for
the for the handle there the blade I
also kind of dusted it a bit with some
flat black spray-paint to dull it up a
little bit more it still has that look
of steel but dulled it up enough so that
it's not gonna be reflective in the
green screen room so yeah that's it sort
of eternal Christmas alright so I've
also been working on the Christmas
monster puppet thing whatever barney
stuck around and gave me a hand with
some of the parts and yeah so let's take
a look alright for the Christmas monster
looks kind of you know very alien queen
kind of it's kind of dug described it I
found this bat that I had in that my
collection of different bones and
animals and stuff like that so I think
the head actually is gonna be a good
starting point for the head of the
creature you can see that really but
it's kind of it's pretty cool it's
already got the working jaw there I'm
just uh cut the ears off or cut into
them and kind of Reese Culp them a
little bit and then we sculpt the eye
area and stuff and add some latex on the
jaw and stuff to kind of close it in a
little bit but for the most part it's a
good base it's pretty close kind of too
I think it'll be a good skeleton for the
alien design and I'm gonna use some of
this free form sculpt is a two-part
epoxy sculpting epoxy it's pretty much
like plastic sculpt and I've got a
little bit longer working time on it and
so then I'm gonna apply it and sculpt a
little bit and it'll harden on there and
whatever shape I leave it so I need to
do something we get something to put in
the eyes of it to get some little glass
balls for the eyes to kind of make them
look sort of insect like for two reasons
one I didn't want to do like an eye that
I had to make blink or move so giving it
like that kind of spider almost insect
eyes kind of quality makes it easier I
don't have to worry about animating it
necessarily or looking weird if it's not
animated at all so well little short
cuts yeah just kind of like I said cut
the arm lengths and stuff like that too
how I want them and then link them
together using probably just some wire
or something very loose and then cover
it with some latex and stuff like that
and then when I add the rods and I can
manipulate it it'll have a bit more of
an organic kind of motion and stuff like
that so alright so this is the puppet
there'll be a rod that has attached the
tail light to finish painting the tail
maybe rods attach the arms and then the
rod that's attached to the head controls
the head and the body movement and the
jaw so I can open and close pretty
simple mechanism it's just a rod
attached to the back of the head with a
piece of cable or wire that I attached
to this clothespin attached to the one
end and drilled the hole goes to the
other end so
yeah works the mouth and stuff pretty
simple and then we can kind of film it
live-action or whatever Doug I can kind
of direct us how he wants the action to
be on the day of so I don't have to stop
do a stop-motion thing or build a giant
costume or anything like that it's a
little simpler and hopefully it works
yeah run around there's also you can
branches have the tail up already okay
yeah okay ready and action
that looked really good super good dad I
think we're going to need to have this
come through there okay let me not get
cuz a guy was getting away at the tail
but it looked like the move and
everything was good right
cool one more animals okay pump it to
the test
or one more time
okay are you ready and free is it fire
awesome when you move forward before
word to say okay perfect right ready
great we'll do one more yeah yeah as
like maybe crew room but they bring the
hands out like it's going cause we're
like it's like up take this I almost
seems like maybe it's recoiling okay
okay okay you ready and action
good the profile shot and I'm going to
say act I'm gonna say boom and yeah
let's try one not using the tailor much
in that one where we do so this one do
not use the tail them but okay yeah but
but on the next one we're really
utilizing give me almost like you're
looking down like yeah that's that's not
that that's it yeah cookies what aunt
you fly-in can the head look down so
it's following you into it then I like
the idea doesn't see yeah okay okay yeah
that that look good okay we good okay
move your right you say hit that way
there you go alright already
boom that's really good okay
going to it
well guys I hope you enjoyed this little
behind-the-scenes look and once again
thank you so much for tuning in and
watching I really appreciate it and yeah
hopefully I'll have some more stuff for
you coming up we're about to get ready
to do some big reviews and I'll have a
little bit of behind the scenes that
upcoming stuff and again I apologize
we're not doing these more often I've
been working on a lot of projects and
some personal projects and stuff like
that and I promise to have some cool
behind-the-scenes footage of that
project coming in the future so once
again you guys Rock
take care
[Music]
you